the Apple watch is finally here again
but this time it actually works unlike
the demo models we saw almost six months
ago the watch is now fully functioning
with the software it'll be carrying when
it ships it comes in this 42 millimeter
size that I'm wearing here and a smaller
more comfortable 38 millimeter size you
do give up a lot of screen real estate
though for that extra comfort unlike the
iPhone the Apple watch doesn't use
multi-touch gestures but it can
differentiate between something like a
quick touch and a more deliberate tap it
also has this digital crown which lets
you move through menus and scroll around
and zoom in to things it also tracks
your health and fitness and sleep a lot
like most of the fitness trackers on the
market these days it does not have GPS
or cellular connectivity relying on your
iPhone for that sort of functionality
there's no word yet also about onboard
storage for things like photos battery
life will be approximately 18 hours to
maximize this the screen goes dark when
you're not doing anything and turns back
on when you raise your wrist
this should mesh pretty well with the
battery life of your iPhone and is on
par with other devices on the market
prices are gonna be 349 to 399 for the
aluminum Apple watch sport 549 to 1099
for the steel Apple watch and a whopping
$10,000 for the solid gold Apple watch
edition free sale will begin on April
10th when the watches will be available
for preview and retail stores with
delivery on April 24th